[Musique]
rien que la vérité enregistrant
magnétique 20 1213 diffusion le 11
janvier 71 deuxième fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis quelques semaines déjà le
téléspectateur peut se familiariser avec
un nouveau jeu que vous présentez rien
que la vérité
pourtant on retrouve une certaine
ressemblance avec le vrai ou faux qui
s'est déroulé cet été sur l'antenne
quelle est la différence justement avec
les jeux précédents non sur le plan du
vol il faut bien dire qu'il n'y en a pas
parce que il y a plusieurs principes si
vous voulez de jeu qui sont immuables
bon ou bien vous poser des questions
il ya ce moment là tous les jeux vont
poser des questions via qu'ils ont un
point commun c'est qu'ils posent des
questions bien mais vous procédez par
affirmation ya pas du moment où procéder
par affirmation forcément d affirmation
est vraie l'affirmation d'une chose donc
tous les jeux procédant par affirmation
ce point commun aussi maintenant ce qui
différencie les jeux c'est un mécanisme
qui leur est propre
et là il ya un mécanisme propre année de
vérité un ghetto où je dirais c'est que
notre but dans ce jeu est d'introduire à
travers ces affirmations vraies ou
fausses
un certain nombre d'idées reçues nous ne
prenons jamais évidemment du moment nous
allons introduire l'idée reçue car les
gens se méfiant sa chance est l'idée
reçue dirai toujours qu'il est fausse
donc il faut qu'elle arrive d'une
manière inattendue c'est pourquoi elle
est mêlée à des quantités de
d'affirmations qui ne sont pas des reçus
mais ils vous diront que nous distillons
environ
deux ou trois idées reçues par
questionnaire et je sais qu un petit peu
faire le point sur six était reçue que
nous avons créé cette émission nous
avons donné comme exemple tout à fait au
début du jeu l'exemple de la tour eiffel
avant que nous commencions avec la
vérité il y avait encore à peu près 85 %
des français qui étaient persuadés
qu'atos elle était montée sur vérins
hydrauliques tout le monde dise
attention suce moi c'est quand hier m'en
faut et en donnant cette affirmation est
en en faisant la preuve d' erreur je
crois que c'est amusant fait de le faire
et c'est amusant de faire ses preuves
devant le devant téléspectateurs ça déjà
je passais une différence essentielle
parce que ce n'était pas le but du jeu
de cet été affirmation à voici un
pointer affirmation b les écrevisses
marche aussi bien en avant qu'en arrière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait le but le but de pierre sabbagh
être honnête c'était 2-2 de retrouver un
petit peu les mécanismes de l'homme du
20e siècle
c'est à dire de faire jouer d'abord et
avant tout chose de téléspectateurs le
but de nec la vérité ce n'est pas
tellement de présenter un spectacle à
suspense les candidats fantastique c'est
pas du tout cela les candidats sont là
un peu comme catalyseur ils sont là pour
que le téléspectateur s'identifient à
eux et joue encore plus facilement mais
en fait nous adressons surtout de les
spectateurs et ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que des spectateurs je joue devant
son écran paris en même temps que nos
candidats jouent ou au même rythme du
mécanisme à poser aux candidats
voyez ce que je dis alors la psychologie
ni candidat bon elles existent dans tous
les jeux la question n'est pas là mais
c'est beaucoup moins important dans ce
jeu là que dans un jeu comme pas une
seconde à perdre la tête et les jambes
et est-ce que techniquement vous avez
des problèmes particuliers sur cette
émission
oui bien sûr on l'a on a toujours eu des
petits problèmes sur toutes les
émissions là disons que vous l'avez vu
le moment essentiel du jeu c'est le
moment présent évidemment les deux
affirmations et elles sont là il fallait
présenter deux affirmations ce qui fait
déjà deux images sur les camps il
fallait présenter les trois candidats ce
qui d'un seul coup d'un seul fait cinq
images son écran est encore plus sûr
impressionné ce qu'ils répondent c'est à
dire s'ils choisissent les formations à
ou l'infirmation believe et si l'image
sur l'écran en même temps est il vrai
que tout ça soit lisible
alors la solution paraît très simple
mais une a fallu pas mal cherché avant
de trouver ces dispositions géométriques
nous ont placé les trois visages on
écran les deux images en bar et c'est
sur imposition enfin c'est sa demande et
hassan et certaines recherches ça paraît
très simple comme ça mais en fait cette
demande pas mal de temps de recherche
tap tap tap
bon allez reprenait il est sur abbey
l'a4 à ce moment là oui mais non mais
les laiteries monk il en manque une quoi
abbas est là bon allez allons à la
droite était pas un trucage non non
l'ipad c'est bien c'est l'île et sur le
droit pour un deux trois autres caches 4
sur ab je sais pas ce qu'il faut c'est
une certaine imagination pour que créer
des questions fausses oui et c'est là
alors surtout nous entrons dans le
domaine le plus dangereux et je suis sûr
je le dis davance d'ailleurs voyez vous
depuis mon dieu de combien d'années sont
des jeux depuis 1950
ça fait donc 15 ans à la bêtise 15 16
nous faisons donc des jeux depuis 16 ans
et révision est en tout et pour tout je
peux me frapper la poitrine
quatre ou cinq fois c'est à dire que
environ nous avons fait quatre cinq
erreurs dans le jeu et rock nous oblige
à reprendre le candidat revenir en
arrière
reconnaître cette erreur sur erreur
grave si vous voulez vous ont peut-être
sur les petits détails des pk 10 et
mater du plus mais pas dans des erreurs
graves n'a eu qu'à tous ceux qui
prennent pas trop considérable vu la
masse de jeux et de question que nous
avons posée mais mais dans le jeu nous
avons entrepris la le risque beaucoup
plus grand
car en effet parfois mon phone à
venthône information fausse parce que
cette épouvantable c'est bien te prend
le plus grand risque dans cette dans
cette forme de jeu je suis sûr que il
faut encore que nous veillions davantage
alors comment comment maintenant cela se
fait nous avons d'abord les concepteurs
derrière il y a les documentalistes qui
vont chercher les éléments dits lui
mais en même temps elles vont l'a
vérifié forcément parce qu'elles vont
l'avoir aussi sous les yeux en tête
alors ça c'est en fait ça sert de
deuxième vérification une fois les
documents trouvés ils vont passer sous
l'oeil d'un laboratoire l'appareil
photographique qui va les photographier
les cadres est pour les mettre aux
formats nécessaires à l'émission et à
nouveau nous allons avoir un autre
contrôle là au moins de droits encore
personnes vont les voir enfin ils vont
venir ici les documents auprès et avant
d'être envoyés soit intel ils vont être
vérifiées par jean paul rault de divine
dernière fois et enfin il va seul en
tête manette ça notre région nous avons
retiré un carton au dernier moment parce
que nous avions écrit fixe avec deux
aides et personne ne l'avait fait malgré
tout la chaîne que je viens de vous
décrire
alors il a d'une part de il a deux
boutons ici bouton correspondant lettres
20 un bouton correspondant à être déçus
on qu'il choisit la formation a ou b ou
bien deuxièmement il ya deux ans lui le
nombre de points qu'il a totalisent au
moment même ce nombre de points qui a
répété sur la face du bureau ici pour le
téléspectateur
il l'a lui aussi sait tout de même nom
bon d'autre part il a un jeu de cartes
tout traitement
là c'est un monsieur qui a des traits
l'autre les coeurs et les barreaux bon
et il m'indique s'il parie un deux trois
quatre ou cinq points d'une manière
confidentielle en retournant une table
une carte sur la table et là en appuyant
sur les boutons il choisit voile est
choisi c'est l'affirmation aquila bol il
appuie sur un peu changé plusieurs fois
en cours de route s'il le veut mais dès
qu'un petit musique8 lui donnant le
temps exact de réponse est terminée là
bas notre contrôleur bloque tout y est
on ne peut plus modifier sa réponse mais
pourtant le candidat ou le
téléspectateur qui joue est aidé en ce
sens qu'il y a une réponse exacte et une
réponse fausse
en conséquence ne fait pas seulement
appel à ses propres connaissances
il ya d'autres qualités qui entrera en
ligne de compte oui on va là tant il
peut jouer aussi au hasard je suis
d'accord avec ça peut faire pilot
vaseuses
mais je crois que si je crois pas que
c'est la pratique en général
des spectateurs ni du candidat car sinon
c'est ça c'est un petit c'est très
facile à dire en dehors du jeu quand on
est dans le jeu je ne pense pas qu'on
ait ce réflexe je ne pense pas que
quelqu'un joue comme ça si je crois
qu'il jouera réellement fonction de ses
connaissances
mais il ya tout de même les
connaissances au l'une par rapport à
l'autre
les deux questions peuvent sembler une
presse hostile peut être sûr de l'es22
de l'exactitude de lune est donc
automatiquement une guinée vous tu
m'aimes pas voter à gauche l'été oui ça
ça peut se produire cet excès enfin nous
essayons également de l'attaqué
suffisamment de domaine pour que ça ne
se produise quelque peu et a plusieurs
fois dans l'émission enfin si vous
laissez tellement variés que ça ne peut
pas se produire deux fois à l'arrivée ça
reste un bon alors là cette fois ci tu
ne dis pas non plus servir des secrets
on a fini c'est amusant c'est combien la
nappe à cette heure je pense que c'était
ce jeu notamment les réponses qu'il
avait quelque chose de vrai vous avez
quelque chose à recommander de guy de
maupassant 6,6 lorna parce que on n'a
fait que six wim avec c'est ce qu'on
annonce à son tour les candidats quand
ils arrivent ils sont
à part évidemment ce qui revient à qu'il
mettrait habitués mais il ya une sorte
de prise de contact et c'est finalement
je crois qu'il faudrait parce qu'on est
une émission n'importe quoi à chaque
fois complètement intégré sais pas ce
que c'est après la première émission qui
est logique il enregistre maintenant on
préfère annuler la première émission il
recommencer ça nous fait des missions de
perdu mais on peut dire ça alors au cinq
émissions dans ces six ans fait ses
premières et produits quoi quand on est
oui que je reste la bamboo un voyant le
répète ici je vienne ici que j semaine
une autre épreuve arrive on se sert à
rien j'ai l'habitude chez les passeurs
ont changé et ça fait une caméra en bleu
lui si tous les candidats qui viennent
participer à l'émission ont été
sélectionnés avant oui par à monsieur
sont mes yeux doux c'est notre grand
sergent recruteur monsieur douce et et
arty cinq jours sur sept en province et
il fait des séances des brevets
dînatoire dans les villes de province
car pierre sabbagh a tenu absolument
comme loeb et 20e siècles à ce que nous
éloignons de paris car il faut le dire
sommes déjà très centralisé le sommet
jeune haut-rhinois parisien ancien plus
de 5 pendant l'été d'un parisien ce
n'est plus drôle du tout alors nous nous
avons le même écartée pour l'instant
complètement paris la compétition et
nous prenons essentiellement des
candidats de province et ont lieu
également d'aller uniquement dans les
stations vertes et à deux provinces qui
sont en général
ville de la portance nous nous avons
également élargi et nous allons dans les
salles des fêtes de certaines petites
mairies dans des villes de moyenne
importance de manière à élargir le plus
possible champ de recrutement et haquin
même à tous les téléspectateurs de jouer
c'est à dire que absolument certain que
monsieur douce et notre siège au
contraire passera dans une ville proche
domicile des téléspectateurs forcément
dans l'aide et comment procède-t-il
justement et bien c'est extrêmement
simple nous continuons exactement la
même manière il a avec lui un projecteur
de diapositives
il a une liste de questions qui se
posent montre d'une affirmation je veux
dire qu'il donne oralement par rapport à
ces dispositifs qui sont exactement
semblable aux illustrations que vous
voyez sur votre écran et les candidats
ont des feuilles répond ce numéro dès
lors il ya trente questions et mérité de
20 à 30 en trois colonnes de 10 les dix
premières sont de niveau du syndicat
d'études les dix suivants du niveau du
brevet dition du niveau du baccalauréat
sont menées en gros ou point de vue
niveau de savoir connaissance est en
phase de chacune des affirmations il
coche vrai qu'il faut selon que je sais
moi tout simplement
mais alors là nous avons déjà une
première de physionomie ce n'est pas
l'essentiel je dis tout de suite une
folie entre cette copine votre mauvaise
mais là le physique guy lacombe beaucoup
de sa façon de s'exprimer alors le
monsieur doucet a également écrit à
l'appareil photographique qui prend
immédiatement et développer les photos
et il avec pluie et mini cassel pour
enregistrer dans la voix des candidats
et avec ce matériel il revient à paris
nous voyons les épreuves éliminatoires
nous vous entendons les voies nous
voyons les photographies et c'est
finalement au vu de tout cela que nous
sélectionnons deux candidats par semaine
puisque je vous signale le troisième lui
est toujours le gagnant de la semaine
d'or est donc de nouveau candidat par
semaine sélection
[Applaudissements]
affirmation à dans l'opérette célèbre
ddc maurice chevalier qui créa le rôle
de dédé affirmation b cette photo est
extraite de l'opérette monsieur carnaval
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'ailleurs voilà des exemples aussi à
monsieur par exemple qui subit les
épreuves éliminatoires a qu'un
brouillard dont la feuille des preuves
la photographie et la cassette avec sa
voix notre monsieur aussi quimper de
brest en fait c'étaient les quantités
nous prenons bien sûr les photographies
et les vois que des candidats et en val
d abomination satisfaisant bien entendu
mais par exemple supposons sur 30 points
possibles un concurrent à 25 l'autre à
23 mais celui de 23 à une voix et un
physique bien meilleure pour plus
télégénique si vous voulez nous
choisirons la lancement la côte d'amour
joue un petit peu de tout de suite
lorsqu'il n'y a pas caché qu est ce que
vous cherchez vous et monsieur douce et
à travers les candidats que vous
sélectionnez pour rien que la vérité
eh bien nous cherchons à ce qu'il soit
un niveau des miroirs si vous voulez
vous qu'ils allaient jouer puisque nous
intéressons surtout téléspectateurs qui
va jouer c'est lui qui nous intéresse il
faut que les candidats qui soit l'image
et qu'il va voir en face de lui
soit un petit peu à un miroir pour lui
dire qu'il puisse parfaitement
s'identifier à ces candidats
donc il faut qu'ils soient d'un certain
il faut qu'ils soient d'un certain
physique qu'ils aient une certaine
présence qu'ils existent et nous les
voulons comme il ya trois candidats les
plus opposés aux autres de manière à ce
que chacun est son favori en fonction
celui auquel il s'identifie le mieux
votre favori c'est forcément celui qui
vous est sympathique celui avec lequel
vous avez envie envie de faire alliance
alors voilà c'est cela il faut donc
qu'ils aient une certaine personnalité
il faut qu'ils aient à sanaa physique il
faut surtout enfin c'est l'essentiel
c'est n'y a pas 36 mots pour définir un
candidat un candidat un bon candidat
bien sûr c'est avant tout une présence
si les présents si vous ne voyez sur
l'écran c'est gagné et je le dis tout de
suite nous raterons bien souvent car
vous se fait souvent des illusions et ça
il faut l'avouer parfois en voyant des
photographies envrion même la personne
dans un bureau en entendant dire cette
personne est très bien l'être
et brusquement devant des caméras elle
perd absolument tous ces bruits combien
de fois at-on vu des raconteurs
d'histoires merveilleuses en famille
n'est ce pas et si vous les mettez dans
une terrine raconte plus rien s'est
terminée une simple noyade et ça se
produit également été candidat donc il
ya des déceptions
ça ne manquera pas certainement au cours
de l'année et en conclusion puisque vous
avez l'habitude des jeux depuis un
certain nombre d'années
est ce qu'on peut parler de progression
dans le choix des émissions de jeux on
n'y a pas de produits a pas du tout de
progression alors je crois que les jeux
suivent exactement le cours du temps
c'est à dire qu'ils ont la forme et le
succès de leur époque
prenons le premier jeu j'ai fait des
divisions vous appelez télé match qui a
duré six ans et dans lequel y avait
beaucoup de jeu en fait cet état c'était
une sorte de d'émissions de variétés
nobles qu'elle défie les cinq mini-jeux
en une heure dont un jeu c'est dingue
les gens bien ce jeu était au goût de
l'époque on leur ferait aujourd'hui les
gens je vous projette tout de suite un
kiné scop des archives la tête et les
jambes mais regardable inimaginable de
faire cette émission
moi même quand ça nous arrive à regarder
vous ne devriez pas penseront pas
pensable
alors nous allons passer à la première
manche attention pour la première manche
à vous télé cinéma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai évoque pour vous vous avez 20
secondes pour me répondre oui un buste
un match de football
oui mais mais encore mais chanceux
france ecosse oui et qu'est ce qu'elle a
il ya un billet à 1 1 pénalty et un
penalty qui a été marquée par les bons
afin nous verrons ça tout à l'heure
monsieur voici le deuxième sujet qu'est
ce que c'est que ce petit oiseau et ce
chiffre 11 milles qui est l'oiseau le
nombre d'oiseaux a son importance
ah oui monsieur louis gallois est ainsi
le record d'altitude hélicoptère le
record d'altitude de en hélico voiture
en hélico en effet monsieur et ce record
était de 11000 mètres et il a été battu
par jean boulet à brétigny aussi un
sujet que vous avez trouvé voici le
troisième monsieur regardez bien ceux ci
qu'est ce que ça représente pour sa
course à pied
oui madame 3 comment atteindre inouï à
travailler il ya en effet deux champs
d'algues à trois kilomètres du un
chronomètre qui ne fonctionnait le
record de 100 m 200 m 2 de course à pied
oui vous je voudrais que le nom du
monsieur qui l'a établi de le court
oui et nous avons mis trois chronomètre
parce que précédemment delecourt avait
battu ce record mais il n'avait pas été
homologué parce qu'il n'avait qu'un
chronométreurs mais maintenant ça y est
c'est fait
écoutez ceci monsieur tasca oui nouvelle
chanteuse qui est importante c'est la
chanteuse le plus célèbre actuellement
monsieur elle se rattache de très près à
l'actualité récente
voyez-vous conquois la cadence oui allez
c'est son scandale milan non c'est pas
ça c'est plus récent nous y reviendrons
tout al'air monsieur dernier sujet
regardez ceux ci est ce que c'est ce
petit ensemble vous fait penser à un
événement reste très récent m
pourrais-je dire annoncé le le chalutier
qui est qui vous qui a pris dans ses
filets un sous marin c'est ça monsieur
le c'était le jt le saint léger qui a
été bien surpris de ramener dans ses
filets le sous marin le terrible au de
la royal navy
ceci se passait à 9 minds de la
cornouaille bon monsieur vous ne jouez
vous me donner des précisions sur
laquelle à ça n'est pas le scandale
qu'elle a fait ses adieux c'est à dire
oui mais c'est dû à quoi
les adieux à la scala de milan bon
puisque voilà qui est parfait la coupe
du monde quelques précisions et avons
parlé d'un penalty écossais inapte et ce
penalty a été raté par les échos c'est
ce qui nous a permis de gagner de
participer aux quarts de finale voilà
est de gagner les quelques minutes par
une victoire assez sensationnel ce qui
fait que maintenant peut-être grâce à ce
penalty raté de la part des écossais
nous sommes capables de gagner peut-être
les demi finales de cette coupe du monde
enfin nous ne sommes pas là monsieur
voilà vous avez gagné 5000 francs c'est
une excellente chose et si vous le
voulez bien mais je vous posais des
questions rituelles
est-ce que vous emportez ses 5000 francs
ou est-ce que vous attaquez la deuxième
manche j'avais également je vous dis
mille francs à elle seule je vous le
signale par conséquent elle peut porter
le total de vriendt 15000 je vais
essayer de continuer bon attention aux
grands traits si vous aimez jouer sur un
seul et quatre évènements de la seconde
manche je vous perdez absolument tout ce
que vous possédez un et les 5000 francs
que vous possédez iront augmenter le
prix de la cinquième et dernière manche
de votre jeu vous maintenez votre liste
ensuite quand nous avons lancé pas une
seconde à perdre au début l'ensemble des
critiques télévision dit
c'est un jeu beaucoup trop rapide mais
ça marche à un rythme affolant c'est
insensé qu'est ce que c'est ce jeune
association on les connaît ne peuvent
pas suivre on suit pas 300 écrans et
deux ans plus tard après une petite
interruption
on a repris la formule exacte le
mécanisme question on dira cette
émission qui s'engourdit un peu ces
questions bien lente cette habituée à ce
rythme nous avions lancé pas une seconde
à perdre à un certain rythme parce que
c'était le rythme de l'époque
en fait les jeux sont un peu le reflet
de l'époque où ils se font certains
enfin marche au rythme de la réponse
aujourd'hui
nous refaisons un jeu à 19h27 et qui est
un jeu pour le téléspectateur parce que
c'est un moment de la journée
ce n'est pas encore la soirée une vision
service n'est pas encore engagée
juste avant le journal la soirée
d'intelligence engage à melbourne
avant on n'a pas envie encore des dans
un jeu dramatique à grand jeu à suspense
on va souffrir pour les candidates c'est
donc pas les deux buts de définition ils
ont dû faire jouer les téléspectateurs
les distraire les amuser pendant un
quart d'heure
leurs enfants parce que c'est la détente
c'est juste avant le repas et puis et
puis mon dieu faire des paris eux-mêmes
enfin deux s'amusaient et moi c'est un
jeu de détente c'est tout il n'a pas
d'autre prétention look un cas une
tension dramatique
[Applaudissements]
alors là un petit changement que je
signe tout de suite
chacun de rancoeur a maintenant cinq
cartes 1 2 3 4 5 et ils parient en
plaçant la carte devant lui retourner si
bien que vous pariez dans le secret les
uns des autres
qu'elle vous pariez liane 1 point sur un
point sur le pour la terre et plus en
plus de doutes
hubert moi j'ai pris 2,2 proche des
grévistes qui recule et qui avance et
henry 1 2 3 a pas de trois comme ça
c'est ça ouais moi sur les travis meyer
au point c'est spécial écrevisses du
coup de grâce les aime mais j'ai jamais
prêt
valence est amusant c'est bien eh bien
eh bien eh bien ces missions raison mais
ils ont bien raison même en effet
l'écrevisse eux peut marcher en avant
comme en arrière vous avez donc gagné
trois points
henri sa part bien pour vous il ya trois
fois vous passez à 18 et hubert lui qui
avait pris que deux bien entendu il
monte à 17 il est second
malheureusement il ya ne commence mal en
effet ce n'est pas un point tel que vous
avez vu mais un setter
[Musique]